another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation dr bright is not  allowed to send emails with memetic  hazards attached no not even when  replying to spam dr brightweed don't  care how annoying it is when your inbox  fills up with suspicious links linda's  annoying quote of the day and chain  letters telling you that you have to  forward the email to 10 people or have  bad luck for a year that doesn't make it  okay to reply with  scp-2774 attached that goes for any  other memetic hazard the last thing we  need is more instances of these hazards  floating around in cyberspace take a  breath stand up from the keyboard and  let the spam filter do its job